I don't think everyone needs to get  married I actually don't I don't think  everyone needs to get married I don't  think everyone needs to have kids a lot  of people can't have kids and what  traditionally would happen then is that  people would join religious life whether  you'd become a priest you become a nun  you become a brother you would just  consecrate your singleness you would you  would attach it to something greater  than yourself and many religions do that  but what the culture is selling right  now is no no don't consecrate yourself  to anyone to any family to any God  consecrate yourself to that glass of  rose and you do you honey